our latest Bloomberg West series
bioengineering the census a closer look
at the technology on the frontiers of
medical science today we meet organovo a
company that's found a way to print 3d
print skin take a look at what it's
doing for the beauty industry and how
the technique could one day impact
patient care thank you know all about 3d
printing we'll take a look at this
company that's 3d printing skin organovo
is targeting the beauty industry
supplying skin tissues to L'Oreal who a
new partnership 3d bioprinting works by
taking cellular building blocks and
layering them and building up those
layers into a full matrix in skin it's
nice because it is a layered tissue but
it also has things like glands inside
that so in the middle of each layer you
can start to put the right cells to
create those structures as you build up
organovo says it takes just 30 minutes
to print a tray of skin and it's easy to
scale because skin cells grow so fast
the technology developed out of
Professor Gabe or for Jack's research at
the University of Missouri funded by a
national grant in 2004 and 2005 now a
public company with a 300 million dollar
market cap organovo is focusing on the
beauty industry but there are hopes its
work may one day be used for patient
care 3d printed skin could be used to
heal diabetic ulcers for example and
eventually treat burn victims organovo
is also working on other human tissues
like liver and kidney instead of
replacing their entire liver what about
a liver patch that could replace some of
the function and can delay when they
actually need a transplant things like
that could be in the clinic with
actually within 5 years full organ
transplant is quite a ways off but for
now organovo is staying focused on skin
the goal for this project is full
thickness 3d printed skin and that
first